Sacha Baron Cohen he has work that is
can push this maybe sometimes on the
line sometimes he likes to step over the
line hmm
in a delightful way a very funny man but
I'm wondering what's it like if you're
with your family and you're watching
your husband's work or one of his movies
and it's one of those scenes that he's
kind of famous for how does that go over
with your crowd I would a couple of
memories there once is the the premiere
of Bruno in London where I sat next to
my mom and during one particular scene
my husband's character gives a [ __ ]
to the air but he mines mines it if it
in an incredibly authentic way and I
just was staring at this screen and I
can feel my mum's eyes turned to me at
one point sort of boring into me like
really you married you really this is it
that and anyway it was hilarious and
then another time my dad bless his heart
and his wife came to Cape Town where my
house we were shooting a movie and
wanted to have a set visit and I didn't
check the call sheet as one you know
doesn't think it's right you know and we
we showed up on set and there were there
were these elephants in the distance and
I said to my kids and my dad and
everyone look guys that's where they're
filming let's go over and see what's
happening and so he went over there in
the buggy and my husband was inside an
animatronic elephants vagina and another
elephant was having sex with another
robotic elephant was having sex with my
husband while he was sort of
masturbating it was abaca Tea Party of
elephants some were real some we're fake
as I I can't explain this to the kids
let alone my dad I just said let's get
lunch let's get lunch
well I don't think lunch would have been
the transition there I remember that
scene I remember that scene really well
that's a Charmin say yes yes and Grimsby
with their brothers Grimsby where he he
climbs into the female there and it's
one of the most insane scenes and
produces sperm something I cannot do
okay you got us back on there that were
safely way I would think when you visit
you know for someone to visit so many
scenes you could have dropped in on
where he think about the movie you're
right about it is there a scene where
Sasha's just having tea I'm talking to
another character no no no I think
there's sperm in every scene
[Laughter]